[Music]
on this Friday night from the
trans-canada highway near carvery
Manitoba grief and questions the
investigation into the deadly and
devastating Collision why the community
says this was a tragedy waiting to
happen plus the roadblocks in the way of
trying to improve highway safety
Canada's new contributions to bolster
the battle against Russian aggression it
meets a portion of our NATO obligations
the disappointment with the timeline and
the U.S justice Department investigation
into Minneapolis Police what we saw in
the report is heartbreaking pattern of
unlawful policing that led to George
Floyd's murder
global national with Donna Friesen
good evening we are in Western Manitoba
tonight along the trans-canada highway
where tragedy struck just before noon
yesterday it was here that a transport
truck and a passenger bus collided that
bus filled with seniors on a day trip to
a nearby casino 15 of them died at this
intersection 10 others are injured
police say they have all they the
injured have all been identified the
deceased however have not been
individually identified the people on
board that bus ranged in age from 58 to
88. this photo from the Winnipeg Free
Press shows what the crash site looked
like shortly after it happened the
transport truck veered off the highway
the bus was propelled about a hundred
meters ending up where that burnt patch
is on the grass the trans-canada highway
has since reopened traffic is flowing
again but the lives of those who lost
loved ones have been stopped in their
tracks 10 of the injured are in the
hospital in Brandon and Winnipeg six of
them in critical care and the questions
about how it happened why it happened
are still on answered
we have obtained video footage of the
Collision that was seized from the
semi-truck trailer
this video indicates that the bus
entered the roadway where the
semi-trailer truck had the right-of-way
extensive analysis is being done on the
video before any further determinations
are made
we have Team coverage tonight Melissa
ridgeen is in Dolphin where most of the
people who died are from Eric Sorensen
is looking into the safety issues at
Crossings like this on the busy
TransCanada highway but we begin with
Mike roulet who is here and looking at
what we know so far Mike the RCMP held a
briefing this afternoon what are they
saying about what they know well the
RCMP were very clear that they are not a
signing culpability or laying blame at
this point but they have spoken with the
driver of the semi truck who's been
released from hospital but key to this
investigation will be what the bus
driver has to say and he has yet to be
released
skid marks on the highway a stop sign
torn from the ground and the
unmistakable Scorch Earth left by an
intense fire or all that's left from one
of the deadliest accidents in Manitoba
history oh my gosh it was only yesterday
when First Responders from hours away
and across the province descended on the
stretch of the trans-canada highway
roughly two hours West of Winnipeg near
the town of Carberry after a
semi-trailer hit a bus carrying seniors
on a trip to a casino
15 seniors have been declared dead so
far with another 10 in hospital with
serious injuries it was totally burned
out yeah that passenger vehicle was
totally burned out when I saw it was it
was almost 20 foot feet of a fire flame
and all the
small here's what we know at the
intersection of the trans-canada and
Highway 5 north of Carberry the terrain
is flat visibility unobstructed Highway
one has two lanes in each Direction
separated by a grassy median the RCMP
say the bus from Dolphin was headed
south on Highway 5 where it would have
come to a stop sign with a flashing
stoplight investigators say it passed
through the westbound Lanes of the
trans-canada as a fast-moving
semi-trailer was heading east the
violence of the Collision propelled the
bus over 100 meters down the road onto
the South shoulder Witnesses say victims
were lying on the road after being
thrown from the vehicle the bus caught
on fire burning until only a shell was
left why this happened won't be known
for a long time as far as the vehicle
pulling out further right away I'm not
going to answer that right now I know
that's an answer that people are looking
for that's a real critical point of the
investigation the RCMP deployed forensic
collision and reconstruction experts and
even called in the investigators who
worked the Humboldt bus crash tragedy in
2018. so I would expect that they are
going to be careful with this one
especially if they're calling in the the
officers and the resources that were
involved in the Humboldt crash the area
where the accident occurred is wide open
and it happened just before noon on a
clear day but locals tell global news
they've complained about the
intersection being dangerous for years
in particular the median which isn't
wide enough to allow a truck to
comfortably stop with so much damage to
the bus investigators will have their
hands full this one is going to be a bit
of a tricky to reconstruct given that
we're not necessarily going to see
definitive areas of damage to the bus
because it was all consumed by fire but
again in those types of situations what
we do is we rely on the roadway evidence
as well as the information that we can
obtain from the truck
now Manitoba's chief medical officer of
Health also spoke today and he said how
difficult it was going to be to be able
to identify the deceased
we have a few Avenues to to explore one
would be fingerprint analysis so we are
going to check and see if any of the
reported deceased individuals have
fingerprints on file feeling that the
next step would be to try and identify
the deceased using dental records as
well as features of their medical
history or surgical history which might
be of assistance for instance if they
have any medical prostheses hip
replacements knee Replacements that
would have serial numbers that we could
identify during the post-mortem
examination
now post-mortems will begin on Monday
they have three full-time investigators
working on this and they clearly have a
lot of work left to do Donna all right
Mike drolet thank you nowhere is the
grief more acute than in the city of
dolphin Manitoba about two hours north
of here Melissa ridgeen is in the
community tonight Melissa
Donna just behind me we're here at the
Dolphin Rec Center which today has been
turned into a support center for this
community that's still processing the
aftermath uh aftermath of Thursday's
accident this makeshift space is for
them to gather to find comfort in Solace
as they grieve which will be the next
step for a community that is still very
much in shock
this devastated
um absolutely Sandra and Glenn Coletta
had thought about taking the bus trip to
Sandhills casino on Thursday two hours
away near the town of Carberry but they
didn't Glenn spoke to some who gathered
here in the parking lot of the Dauphin
Senior Center where the bus began a
short fun outing like so many in the
past
they even left their cars here expecting
to be home by dinner no one expected the
worst
we understand tragedy everybody does but
at this magnitude the fact that we lost
15 seniors in our community is
staggering
the senior center was still busy today
but Friday's usual Bingo had more empty
seats than usual they're going going to
the to the casino they would they're
mingle people that like to go to bingo
too the community is drawing support
from the only other place in Canada that
knows how they feel Humboldt
Saskatchewan where a lesson was learned
to tread slowly they said if you don't
have anything concrete to say don't say
it it's just easier to deal with the
delay of information rather than
correcting incorrect stuff like the
Humboldt tragedy Canadians have
responded with an outpouring of support
something of a comfort to the small town
we're a resilient little community and
everybody's pulling together and we're
getting support from literally all
across the country and that's very
reassuring dolphin fire chief Cameron
Avery says while his Department Grieves
likely knowing everyone on that bus
they're thankful to the emergency
responders who attended the crash it's
never an easy process responding to
these and especially the smaller
departments
you know it's nobody signed up for an
incident such as this health officials
in Winnipeg say those who remain in
hospital there face an uphill recovery
age does have a big impact on our
ability to withstand injuries like this
so it it will impact their recovery it
will impact their outcomes as well this
isn't elderly cohort of patients and so
the recoveries will be wrong and their
course could be complicated
city leaders say this Community Support
Center will stay open as long as it's
needed and that it could take days
before it's known exactly who passed and
then the condition of those who remain
in the hospital of course the mayor told
us that a memorial will be held but
they're not rushing to plan such a thing
they're taking the advice from Humboldt
and taking things very slowly
Donna
okay Melissa Ridge and dolphin Manitoba
thank you in the days and weeks ahead
when we know how it happened people will
wonder if anything could have been done
to prevent the Collision this is the
Prairie the intersection where the crash
happened behind me has no traffic lights
there's no overpass of course just stop
signs Eric Sorensen reports in this
country that is not unusual
in big population centers like Toronto
they've taken the intersection out of
highways that intersect with overpasses
and cloverleafs to ensure Crossing
traffic never meets it creates an
efficient and safer traffic flow that's
not what exists in vast stretches of the
country the trans-canada connects the
nation from the east coast to the west
but crisscrosses hundreds of roads
without so-called grade separation well
it makes your heart jump a bit trucker
Travis McDougall just drove from
Manitoba to Ontario and says he has to
watch the intersections closely along
the trans-canada I've probably had more
close calls with somebody else trying to
cross the highway we want to be looking
at
at if there's anybody waiting to cross
right you want to try and watch at an
intersection like the one in Manitoba
it's not one simple calculation to cross
a four-lane divided highway first
there's a stop sign to assess the two
lanes of high-speed traffic coming from
the left and then a yield sign at the
median a precarious moment Midway across
before quickly reassessing what's coming
the other way at high speed and then
proceeding are there safer options
potentially you can install traffic
lights for a couple of hundred thousand
dollars or build a roundabout for
several hundred thousand dollars the
safest would be an overpass but that can
cost many millions of dollars at the
intersection of Manitoba's highways 16
and 1 the Yellowhead and the
trans-canada they installed traffic
lights some years back but there's still
been accidents so the government pledged
to do more we've seen some tragedies
there we are going to design a
roundabout for this intersection three
years later there are still just traffic
lights governments must constantly
review where to spend limited dollars on
expensive infrastructure those options
are not feasible in every intersection
you know when you are in the rural
Canada when you are in the extreme North
we can't have you know overpasses or
traffic lights being placed at every
nooken corner so that is where you know
the technical reviews will come into
place but it's also up to Canadian
drivers approaching intersections
biggest thing is now
don't be afraid to take that second look
MacDougall emphasizes driver training
and always be attentive Eric Sorensen
Global News
the port line for grieving families has
been set up in the region there is a
number to call it is for families it's
204-647-5058 and a support center is
also being run out of the dolphin
Lutheran Church for those who feel they
need it
and in another part of the country in
northern BC there are multiple injuries
after another bus crash this one on a
remote Forest Road the RCMP it's say it
happened north of Prince George this
morning the bus carrying as many as 30
people went off the road and rolled 18
people were then taken to hospital no
one is critically hurt police say the
cause is unclear but rainy weather this
morning had made road conditions there
poor
I will be back from Manitoba a little
later right now far in Nasser has the
rest of the day's news including a major
legal victory for the federal government
Para
Donna the Supreme Court has ruled the
controversial agreement allowing Canada
to send refugees back to the U.S is
constitutional coming up why Advocates
worry about the safety of Asylum Seekers
foreign
Canada's marking a major Milestone today
according to statistics Canada the
country's population officially
surpassed 40 million people this
afternoon the agency says just over 1
million people were added in 2022 alone
that's a record for this country most of
which was driven by immigration if
Trends continue our population will hit
50 million 20 years from now
and there was a major legal Victory
today for the federal government over
who's allowed to enter this country the
Supreme Court upheld the safe Third
Country agreement between Canada and the
United States ruling the deal which lets
this country send refugees back South of
the Border is constitutional both
countries tighten border rules around
the agreement to curb an influx of
migrants earlier this year but as Korea
Israel reports opponents say that's only
left Asylum Seekers more vulnerable
yeah
this once busy Crossing between Quebec
and New York is now quiet a stark
contrast from a year ago
the Canadian government closed the door
to roxham Road by extending something
known as the safe Third Country
agreement the U.S is not a safe country
for refugees
but the Supreme Court of Canada ruled it
is in a unanimous decision the judges
sided with Ottawa in a legal challenge
launched by Refugee claimants the safe
Third Country agreement was signed in
2004. it recognizes both the U.S and
Canada as safe countries meaning
refugees must claim asylum in the first
country they arrive we're going to be
using the agreement to Foster culture of
regular migration but advocacy groups
warn Canada as sending refugees into
Harm's Way There are serious rights
violations and issues that are at stake
when refugees are returned to the U.S
because of conditions of detainment and
deportation
for years the agreement only applied to
official border crossings because of a
loophole that led to an influx of
migrants in places like Emerson Manitoba
and rockson Road Quebec I was a refugee
claimant Crossing through the roxan road
naqib sarwari is originally from
Afghanistan and now works for Amnesty
International they will put them in
further danger as they cross through
unofficial ports of Entry through
Farmers fields and through relying on
Smugglers we uh provinces like Quebec
argue they don't have the resources to
cope with the arrivals in the ruling the
Supreme Court of Canada says there are
safety valves to exempt refugees in
certain cases from the agreement but
advocacy groups say those safety valves
only exist on paper and not in practice
teria is rate Global News Ottawa
to Europe next where NATO's defense
ministers have just wrapped up two days
of meetings in Brussels the summit saw
new announcements of more money and
weapons to help Ukraine but there are
also efforts to strengthen Europe's
defenses against Russia's aggression
Beyond this conflict Canada was among
those vowing to do more to ensure that
that happens as David Akin reports some
of those new commitments include sending
a tank Squadron
The Leopard 2 tanks are from Canadian
Forces bases near Edmonton and
engagetown New Brunswick they'll start
arriving this fall in Latvia right on
NATO's Baltic border with Russia
Canada's defense minister Anita Anand
says their deployment demonstrates
Canada's resolve to defend NATO
territory let me be clear
Canada and all NATO allies will always
defend every inch of NATO territory and
we are deploying the necessary
capabilities and Personnel to make good
on that promise 130 Canadian Forces
Personnel will move overseas with 15
tanks to join the 600 Canadians who are
already in Latvia as part of a NATO
battle group it's a demonstration of
resolve we have this kind of capability
it is I think really important for
Canada to kind of Step Up and I'm glad
that the minister and the Canadian
Forces are doing this and yet it will
not be until the spring of 2024 when the
tank Squadron is fully operational
retired lieutenant general Andrew Leslie
a former tank commander himself is
disappointed it will take so long it
just points to how we need more
resources and more focus at the
political level to actually get things
done faster at NATO HQ in Brussels
Canada also announced it will give
Ukraine 10 000 artillery shells and 288
air defense missiles Canada will also
join its NATO allies in training
Ukrainian Pilots to fly F-16 fighter
jets David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
it's been three years since George
Floyd's murder ahead the damning
findings into the conduct of Minneapolis
Police
it's been two years since Minneapolis
Police Officer Derek Chauvin was
convicted of George Floyd's murder now a
federal investigation has determined
that the city's Police Department
engaged in a pattern of racial
discrimination and excessive force and
as Jackson prosco reports its hopes the
findings of this report will lead to
long-awaited reforms
George Floyd's murder shocked the nation
for many black and Indigenous residents
of Minneapolis it also confirmed what
they knew all along the patterns and
practices we observed made what happened
to George Floyd possible a review by the
U.S department of justice found
Minneapolis Police engaged in a
widespread pattern of misconduct
violating the Constitutional and civil
rights of citizens MPD
unconstitutionally uses bodily Force
too often they say police use dangerous
neck holes as they did with George Floyd
MPD officers responded to a person's
statement that they could not breathe
with the version of you can breathe
you're talking right now the Department
of Justice investigation was launched
the day after former officer Derek
shovin was convicted of Floyd's murder
its 28 recommendations to improve police
income too little too late for many we
are grateful that the Department of
Justice has fine Emily decided to
intervene this intervention was long
overdue Minneapolis has already
undertaken drastic reforms to policing
soon its Police Department could be
governed by a binding agreement with
Federal officials our success will be
defined by the people of Minneapolis
feeling safe with so little trust in
policing Minneapolis will have to do
more than just promise change officers
will have to deliver it
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
[Music]
the Canadian flag on Parliament Hill has
been lowered to pay respects to the
victims that the Collision in Carberry
and in the House of Commons a moment of
silence this morning
Donna will be back in Manitoba in a
moment
welcome back to Manitoba as we say
goodbye tonight we want to leave you
with some of the voices of the people
who are involved in the investigation of
the crash at this intersection on the
trans-canada highway and those who are
consoling the community which is reeling
from so many lives lost thanks for
watching
people will grieve in different ways
obviously I was impressed with the
tactfulness that the rtmp and the mental
health workers were showing and um it it
just it's sad and that's about all I can
really say at this moment but time will
will help us and um we're just we're
just very grateful for the the
outpouring of support from folks and if
I can say anything
um
um if you know people have asked what
can we do and all I would ask is that if
you know someone in our community or
you're friends with someone here a reach
out you know give them a call send them
a message let them know you're thinking
about them because I know that that
that's been tremendously helpful so far
and certainly will be needed over the
next hours and days and weeks as we deal
with this a tragedy this magnitude
requires strong Partnerships
I want to thank the countless First
Responders and supporting agencies that
quickly attended the Collision to do all
they could to help those in need our
deepest condolences to all those have
been affected their thoughts are with
the community of dolphin and all of
Manitoba